EXCUSE ME, BRIT.
SENIOR DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
TELLING OUR OWN JACOBSON,
"SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER IS NOT
RECOMMENDING ANY FURTHER
INDICTMENTS."
AGAIN, THE NEWS FROM
"SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER
NOT RECOMMENDING ANY FURTHER
INDICTMENTS."
>> THAT'S SIGNIFICANT, BRET --
ALTHOUGH WHEN IT COMES TO THIS,
THE QUESTION WE ARE ALL WAITING,
FINALLY AT LONG LAST THE
QUESTION OF COLLABORATION, IT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED AT SOME LENGTH
THROUGHOUT ALL OF THIS WEATHER
IF THERE WERE SUCH
COLLABORATION, IT WOULD BE A
CRIME.
IF MR. MUELLER DECIDES THAT NO
INDICTMENTS SHOULD ENSUE BECAUSE
OF THAT, THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEANS HE DIDN'T FIND
ANYTHING IMPROPER HANKY-PANKY
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
THE RUSSIANS, IT MAY JUST BE
THAT HE FOUND IT WASN'T
CRIMINAL.
MY OWN SENSE ABOUT THIS IS IT'S
HARD TO IMAGINE TO COME AS FAR
AS WE HAVE WITH AS MUCH EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO INVESTIGATE
THIS WHOLE MATTER BOTH INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE THE GOVERNMENT THAT
IF THERE HAD BEEN SUCH A THING,
WE WOULDN'T HAVE HEARD ABOUT IT
BY NOW.
BUT IT IS WORTH KEEPING IN MIND
THAT THERE IS THIS LEGAL
QUESTION OF WHETHER IF IT HAD
BEEN TURNED UP, WOULD IT HAVE
EVEN BEEN A CRIME, AND THEREFORE
IF THERE ARE NO FURTHER
INDICTMENTS, IT MIGHT NOT MEAN
THAT THEY FOUND NOTHING IMPROPE
IMPROPER.
>> Bret: SURE.
THERE'S A LOT THAT WE DON'T KNOW
YET, BUT THAT SENTENCE IN IT OF
ITSELF, AFTER ALL THE MONTHS AND
MONTHS OF SPECULATION OF WHAT
COULD HAPPEN, THE FACT THEY
COULD SAY THAT THIS SPECIAL
COUNSEL REPORT DOES NOT
RECOMMEND ANY FURTHER
INDICTMENTS.
JUST ON ITS FACE, ITS RIGHT TO
POINT OUT THAT THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK IS
CONTINUING ITS INVESTIGATION,
THAT THERE ARE MORE
INVESTIGATIONS ON CAPITOL HILL,
BUT IF THIS REPORT, BRIT, DOES
NOT DELIVER THE PUNCH THAT
PERHAPS CRITICS OF THE PRESIDENT
OR DEMOCRATS HAD HOPED IT WOULD
AND IT SEEMED LIKE THE COVERAGE
OF IT IN RECENT DAYS, THERE WAS
A PREPARATION FOR THAT FACT UP
ON CAPITOL HILL, IF IT DOESN'T,
WITH THE PRESIDENT THEN TAKE
THAT AND SAY, SEE, I TOLD YOU
SO, YOU NEED TO STOP AND MOVE ON
AND GET THINGS DONE?
>> HE UNDOUBTEDLY WILL SAY THAT.
I WOULD SUGGEST THIS, BRET,
DEMOCRATS ON CAPITOL HILL HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SIGNALING THAT EVEN
IF HE DOESN'T FIND ANYTHING IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
COLLABORATION, THAT HE, THAT
THEY INTEND TO PURSUE THAT ISSUE
FURTHER.
PREDICT REALLY ADAM SCHIFF ON ON
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
INTENDS TO PURSUE THAT.
IF MUELLER COMES OUT AND THERE
IS NOTHING SUGGESTING IMPROPER
BEHAVIOR BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
AND THE RUSSIANS BEFORE THE
ELECTION, I THINK A LOT OF THE
POLITICAL WIND WILL GO OUT OF
THE SALES BECAUSE PEOPLE WILL
LOOK AT THIS AND SAY COME ON.
YOU'VE BEEN PURSUING THIS ALL
THIS TIME, NOW MUELLER, BLOWING
AWAY THE OPPONENTS, DIDN'T FIND
ANYTHING FOR IT WHAT ARE YOU
DOING?
MY SENSE ABOUT THAT IS WHILE THE